hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and i often get questions
about the exact sizes of the titans from
the attack on titan story
and how they compare to each other which
titans are the tallest
which are the shortest and so on so
because this is such a hot topic of
discussion
in our community i decided to do a quick
video where i rank
all of the notable titans based on
height from shortest to
tallest if you enjoy our attack on titan
videos and you want to see
more please leave a like and comment it
only takes a second
but it helps a lot and if you're new to
the channel or maybe you just watch our
videos but you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications the only way to make
sure you won't miss our videos in the
future
is to click subscribe hit that bell and
then select the option that says
all i know it's annoying it's an extra
step but that's how youtube works
by the way don't forget to check out our
large and growing
attack on titan video playlist i will
link the playlist in the description
and in the pinned comment so definitely
check it out if you're looking for more
attack on titan content
finally this video will contain attack
on titan manga spoilers we are talking
about all the titans in the story so
please
proceed with caution you have been
warned
okay now just a quick note when it comes
to the pure titans also known as the
mindless titans i will speak
in general terms i won't be trying to
determine the exact
height of every single titan npc
also for some of the titans i will be
discussing their exact height is
simply unknown so the best that we can
do
is make an educated guess based on the
information
and images that are available with that
said let's start off
with the mindless or pure titans these
guys can vary greatly when it comes to
height
and their general range is between 2
meters and 15 meters in height
even though 2 meters is widely believed
to be the smallest
titan size and that is the smallest size
listed on the official attack on titan
wiki
the actual small titans we've seen tend
to be closer to 3 meters
and i mean that makes sense since there
are plenty of normal humans out
there who are 2 meters in height or
taller so having a titan who is about as
tall as a tall
human kind of defeats the purpose of the
name titan
some notable mindless titans that we've
seen within that
2 to 15 meter range include the titan
coney's dad turned into who was about
3 meters tall sunny who was about 4
meters tall
bean who was about 7 meters tall and
dina fritz's smiling titan
who was between 14 and 15 meters tall
mindless titans comprise the vast
majority of all the titans that we've
seen in the story
and their behavior is quite predictable
they are known for simply going after
the first human they see
in an attempt to devour them however
abnormal titans
are far more unpredictable they might
ignore the humans who are closest to
them and
choose to instead go after other
individuals or groups of individuals who
are much further away
they might even exhibit some very
strange behavior for a titan such as
running quickly
jumping or even talking okay now let's
talk about the kart titan
the only titan shifter who walks
exclusively on
all fours due to the fact that it
doesn't walk on two legs
the car titan stands at only about four
meters in height
and that puts it on the lower end of
even the mindless titan height range
just a bit taller than the cart titan is
the jaw titan
who tends to be roughly 5 meters in
height regardless of its user
this is likely because the jaw titan's
signature abilities include speed
and agility and this requires a smaller
lighter body
then we have the founding titan form of
frieda reese
frieda's founding titan is about 13
meters in height
so now we're getting into the bigger
titans the attack on titan wiki
also lists carl fritz's founding titan
at about 13 meters
although i am not so sure about that we
only get like one still image of that
titan in the entire story
but based on that image alone he appears
to be taller than 13 meters
at least in my opinion it might just be
the angle of the image
but compared to the humans below it to
me carl fritz's titan's height
looks closer to the height of the
colossal titan than the height of
frida's founding titan
let me know down in the comments what
you guys think about carl fritz's
founding titan and how tall
it was does 13 meters sound right to you
or do you think that he was taller
alright now let's move on to the female
titan
annie is the only known female titan
shifter in the story
and her titan is about 14 meters in
height
just a bit taller than the female titan
we have the attack titan
who is around 50 meters in height
regardless of the user
reiner's armor titan is also about 15
meters in height
as is lara tiber's warhammer titan
after that we have zeke's beast titan
who stands at an impressive 17 meters
in height from what we've seen so far
the beast titan forms
very greatly depending on their user so
we can assume that the height
of the beast titan will also be
drastically different
depending on the user then we have the
wall titans
the thousands of abnormal titans who
were sealed away
inside the three walls on paradise
island
they all closely resemble the colossal
titan shifter
but they are believed to be about 10
meters shorter
the colossal titan shifter is 60 meters
in height
and the walls are 50 meters tall so the
assumption is that the wall titans are
about 50 meters as well
however there are people who believe
that the legs of the wall titans were
partially buried in the ground
when they were sealed away inside the
walls and so their true height
after they break free from the wall
could be around 60 meters
just like the colossal titan shifter
following the colossal titans
imposing 60 meter height the next titan
that we need to talk about
is rodris's abnormal titan who was a
staggering
120 meters in height twice the size of
the colossal
titan even though this was an abnormal
mindless titan
and not a titan shifter for a very long
time
this was by far the biggest titan that
we had ever seen
due to this titan's massive size and
disproportional bodily dimensions
it was unable to stand upright without
support and most of the time
it had to crawl on the ground the only
time that it was able to stand was while
using the wall
for support now let's talk about emir
fritz's
original founding titan the very first
titan
and the only one to hold all nine titan
shifter powers
within one person it is difficult to
determine this titan's exact size
because all we have are a couple of
manga panels as reference points
this titan appears to have been
considerably bigger than even the
colossal titan
but how much bigger is the real question
i've seen various estimates about emir's
titan's height
that range from like 100 meters to all
the way up to 240 meters
some have argued that emir fritz's titan
had to have been smaller than rod
reese's titan
because rod reese's titan couldn't even
walk upright without support
so theoretically if emir's titan was
even bigger
then how could it have walked well first
of all emir's titan had very different
proportions
and a totally different bodily structure
than the rod reese titan
so in that sense it's not an exact
comparison
and also in the manga we never actually
see emir's titan form
standing completely upright so it is
possible that she spent
most of her time crawling on the ground
rather than walking
upright my personal guess is that emir's
titan was indeed
bigger than rods and that she was about
200 meters in height
when standing completely upright and
finally we have the biggest titan in the
history of attack on titan
aaron's absolutely gigantic founding
titan
form this skeletal spider-esque titan
is something straight out of a horror
film and as with emir's titan
we don't have an exact measurement for
him all we have to go by
are a number of manga panels the
estimates i've seen for this titan's
height
also vary wildly i've seen estimates as
low as 350 meters and as high as
900 meters i even tried to do my own
calculations by measuring the wall
titans in a panel right next to aaron's
new titan form
and then using their size of roughly 50
meters as a point of comparison
by my calculations aaron's founding
titan
is at least 500 meters in height and
that is a conservative estimate
but regardless of what his exact height
is
aaron's gigantic founding titan form is
by far the biggest titan
in the attack on titan story and
that is it all the notable titans ranked
from
shortest to tallest i know that a lot of
this was speculation and educated
guessing so feel free to let me know
if you disagree with any of the
estimates in this video
and of course don't hesitate to give me
your own personal estimates and
guesstimates
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more attack on titan content right here
on the channel
please leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime outpour or
maybe you've been watching our videos
but you didn't subscribe yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications
don't forget to check out our large and
growing attack on titan video playlist
i will link it down in the description
and in the pinned
comment you can also hit me up on
twitter
and instagram at animeopror
a big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
the world a quiet respect pate heffa
liam thompson
algital dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life tinel baked
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell cruise
anatoly kazotsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
fond ruthlin de ora alicia octor bonnie
parks hinokami and water the red-haired
raven joanne garcia jack watches anime
fat boy games ted no ted deadly saint
matthew cruz and anthony schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you